the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
let's get on with some dynamics so the
place the place I'm going to begin is
just comment about mechanical
engineering courses the first and you
may have heard this already in classes
you'll be taking subjects to double-o
one if your course two majors through to
double-o nine and if you're to a most of
the odd ones but the subjects to
double-o one through two double-o five
are really basically engineering science
subjects are all foundational to
mechanical engineering and they all have
a common sort of property to them and
that is that we make observations of the
world and we we ask you know we try to
understand them we post problems you
know why you know four hundred years ago
is the Sun the center of the solar
system or not and we try to produce
models that explain the problem so
here's the problem the question of the
day we try to produce models to describe
it and we make observations measurements
to see if our models are correct and we
feed that information back into the
models we try out the models we test it
against more observations you go round
and round and this is kind of the
fundamental business away all of these
basic first five subjects use basically
this method of inquiry so in 2 W 3 the
way this system works my kind of mental
conception of this modeling process is
three three things and this applies to
you have a homework problem
you attack a homework problem you're
going to need to describe the motion
you're going to need to choose the
physical laws pick I'll call it because
it's short the physical law that you
want to apply like F equals MA
conservation of energy conservation of
momentum we got to know which physical
laws to apply and then finally third you
need to apply the correct math then
that's really most most dynamic problems
can be broken down this way this is a
way I like to conceptually break them
down you might have another model but
this is the way I'm going to teach it so
you can you describe the motion pick the
correct physical laws to apply to the
problem and apply the be able to do the
correct math solving the equation of
motion for example and this is all this
is what fits in our models box and we
test it against observations and
measurements and improve those things
over time so I'm going to give you how
many of you like history I find a
history and history of technology kind
of fun and interesting so I'm going to
throw a little bit of history into
giving you a little quick course outline
a power of what we're going to do in
this subject this term
because the history of dynamics and what
we're going to do in the course actually
track one another remarkably closely so
if I ever gave you a bunch of names like
Galileo Kepler Descartes Newton
Copernicus Euler Lagrangian breaky which
one comes first take a guess
good like Copernicus so Copernicus was
polish and the story starts long before
then but you know about 1500 Copernicus
said what
the sun's the center what he's or or the
earth is the center what did he say yeah
so told me you know back around 130 ad
said while the sun's us the Earth's
center of the of the solar system
Copernicus came along and said nope I
think that in fact the sun's the center
of the solar system and for the next 100
years more than a hundred years a couple
hundred years it was really raging
controversy about that
so Copernicus Bray he Kepler
so I'm putting them in rough
chronological order here now I'm going
to run out of board well
Galileo Descartes
energy
okay Descartes Newton Euler and LaGrange
so we were talking to say a little bit
about each of them and now that I'm like
I told you I haven't used this classroom
before so I learn how to play this game
I need to be able to reach this for a
minute so Bray he he was along about
1600 Bray he was the mathematician the
wrote the Imperial mathematician to the
Emperor in Prague and he did 20 years of
observations and he was out to prove
that the earth was the center of the
solar system and then Kepler actually
worked with him as a mathematician and
then took over as the Imperial
mathematician and he took Bray he's data
twenty years of astronomical data
without the use of the telescope and
used it to come up with the three laws
of planetary motion and so his first and
second laws were put out about 1609 and
you know one of the laws is like equal
area swept out in equal time have you
heard that one that's actually turns out
to be a statement of conservation of
angular momentum which we'll talk about
quite a bit about in the course then
came Galileo and I'm put not putting
their birth and death dates here I'm
kind of putting in period of time in
which kind of important things happened
around him so 401 years ago a really
important thing happened Galileo in 1609
turned the telescope on Jupiter and saw
what four moons right and that then we
really started having some data with
which to really argue against the column
a and view of the world of the solar
system the Descartes
is it is an important figure to us and
in the period of about 16 32 16 44 in
that period Descartes began what is
today known as analytic geometry he was
a geometry studied Euclid a lot but then
he came up with the Cartesian coordinate
system XYZ in the beginnings of analytic
geometry which is essentially algebra
coordinates and geometry all put
together and that we are going to make
great use of analytic geometry in this
course
then came Newton kind of in his his
actual life span 1643 is kind of
interesting he spans these people and in
about 1666
it's when he first the first statement
of the three laws of motion then
boiler and he 1707 to 1783 that's his
lifespan oiler came up you know Newton
never talked about angular momentum he
mostly talked about particles oiler put
Newton's three laws into mathematics
Euler taught us about angular momentum
and torque being DHD key in most cases
and did he's the most prolific
mathematician of all time solve all
sorts of important problems and then
finally is L'Orange and L'Orange in
about 1788 uses an energy method energy
and the concept of work to give us
equations of motion so the course 203
stands on the shoulders of all these
people but with Descartes we start with
kinematics really this is analytic
geometry and that's what we're going to
start today is with kinematics and very
soon thereafter we're going to review
Newton the three laws and what we call
the direct method for finding equations
of motion conservation of momentum fact
that force sum of the forces on a object
equals mass times acceleration or it's a
time derivative of its linear momentum
so that's and we use that to derive
equations of motion so we're going to go
kinematics into doing the direct method
to getting equations of motion and we go
from there into angular momentum and
what Euler gave us the same thing torque
we're going to do quite a lot with
angular momentum because I know you know
a lot about F equals MA and you've done
lots of problems in 801 applying that
done some problems using rigid body
rotations but I think there's a lot more
you need
understand about this and will spend
quite a bit of time on it and they urge
you and then near the last third of the
course we shift because LeGrande said
that if you just write down expressions
for energy kinetic and potential energy
without any consideration of of newton's
laws and the direct method you can
derive the equations of motion that's
pre remarkable so they're actually two
independent routes to coming up with
equations of motion and in this course
and about the last third of the course
we're going to teach you about Lagrange
and all then all of these things are
going to be one of the applications that
are important engine hairs is a study of
vibration so we'll be looking at
vibration examples as we go through the
course and applying these different
methods to first modeling and then
solving interesting vibration problems
which brings I have question for you so
how many of you were in this classroom
last May with Professor Haynes Miller
and I showed up one day and we talked
about vibration how many remember I told
you is going to ask this question right
great ok it's good to see you here again
and we will talk about vibration in this
course so there's kind of the subject
outline built on the shoulders of these
people in history that made important
contributions to dynamics
any questions about the history if you
want to know one of my TAS compiled a
pretty neat little summary maybe I will
see if I can go back and find this I
just printed it out and send it how many
of you like to know a little bit more
about the history these are like two
liners on each person anybody wanted is
it worth my time to send this out okay
that's kind of fun so let's do an
example of this modeling describing the
motion picking physical laws applying
the math and that will get us get us
launched in the course and we'll do it
using Newton and the direct method
so last May pains Miller and I talked
about vibration and let's so let's start
I'm going to start with a vibration
problem and I brought one so here's my a
couple of lead weights and a couple of
Springs so relate you want to talk about
this is a problem I want to talk about
now you've done this problem before
Haynes Miller and I did it last last May
you've no doubt done it in other classes
okay it's a system which has spraying a
mass it exhibits something called a
natural frequency but let's go out let's
see what it takes to it just initially
begin to follow this modeling method to
arrive an equation of motion for this
problem so what do I mean by when I say
describe the motion really what that
boils down to is you have to assign a
coordinate system so that you can
actually say where the objects moving
then I'm going to pick one here so
here's coordinates this will be really
important in this course and I'll give
us an XYZ Cartesian coordinate system
and I'm going to try to adopt the habit
for the most part during the course that
this o marks this origin but it also
names the frame so we could we have
we're going to talk about things that
are reference frames and at a most
important one that we need to know about
in the course is an inertial reference
frame and when you can use it and when a
system is inertial and is not so I'm
going to say that this is inertial
sticks to the earth it's not moving and
we're going to use this coordinate X to
describe the motion of this mass and the
motion is going to be this X is from the
zero spring
force position it's actually quite
important that you pick you have to say
you know what's the condition in the
spring of the system when you when X is
zero so we're going to say it's when
there's no force in the spring means
it's not stretch that's where zero is so
we've established a coordinate system
the second we need to apply physical
laws now I'm going to do this problem by
F equals MA Newton's second law sum of
the external forces is equal to mass
times the acceleration so that's the law
I'm going to apply some of the external
forces it's a vector but we're just
doing the X component only so we don't
have to carry along vector notation is
equal to this case mass times
acceleration that's the law we're going
to apply and then finally the math that
solved the equation of motion that we
find that'll be the third piece but part
of applying the physics in order to do
this now we need what I call an FB D
what do you suppose that is
Freebody diagrams you run and use these
many times before so we're going to do
those and Freebody diagrams and I'm
going to teach you a least the way I go
about doing Freebody diagrams as things
get more and more complicated you have
to you're going to have to be more more
sophisticated in the way that you do
these things so I just have some simple
little rules to do Freebody diagrams
that keep you from getting hung up on
sign conventions I think the thing
people make most mistakes about is they
get confused about signs so I'll try it
I'll show you how I do it
so first you draw the fool you draw
forces that you know basically in the
direction in which they act seems
obvious so when you know the direction
so this is a really trivial problem but
the method here is is very specific see
indeed so what's an example well gravity
so we'll start our Freebody diagram
gravity acts at the center of mass it's
downward what I mean by the direction of
which it acts and it has magnitude M G
okay now the other forces aren't so
obvious the force that's put on by the
stiffness and this damper in the spring
which way do you draw them what's design
what's the sign convention so the
convention the way I go about doing
these things is I assume positive
positive values for the deflections and
velocities so in this case X and x dot
you just require that the deflections
that you're going to work with are
positive and then from the positive
deflection you say which way is the
resulting force so if the deflection in
this is downwards which direction is the
force that the spring applies to the
mass up right what about if the velocity
is downwards which it which direction is
the force that the damper puts on the
mass also up right okay so this this
allows this gives us so here's F spring
and here's F damper and are there any
other forces on this mass
spring force damper force and the
gravitational force whoops
and so third you deduce the signs
basically from the direction of the
arrows first we need what's called your
constitutive relationships so the spring
force FS well you've made X positive so
it keeps things nice the spring
constants a positive number so FS is K X
FD is B X dot and now we write the
statement that the sum of the forces in
the X direction we look at up here we
say well that's going to be FS plus FD
minus mg so that's whoops
what's the wrong way around minus minus
plus because I'm plus downwards right
well spring minus FS is minus KX minus
BX dot plus mg equals MX double dot and
I rearrange this to put all the motion
variables on one side MX double dot plus
BX dot plus KX equals mg so there's my
equation of motion but with a method for
doing the free body diagrams which will
work with multiple bodies so you have
two bodies with Springs in between them
this is when the confusion really comes
up two bodies are the spring trap
between them what's the sign convention
you do the same thing both bodies
exhibit positive motions there is the
force that results is proportional to
the difference and you work it out and
you'll get the signs right okay so
here's our equation of motion arrived at
by doing the direct method and just to
we could use if we went on to the third
step which we're not going to do today
and that is apply the math it might be
because I want you now to describe the
motion for me get solved for the motion
that means solving the differential
equation and that's what we did last May
in the haints Miller's class we'll come
back to this later on but for today's
purposes we don't need to we don't need
to go there
got something else much more important
to get to about kinematics but I want to
show you one thing and that is just just
a little tiny introductory taste to this
point so I've derived the equation of
motion of this by saying by Newton's
laws but I'm going to ignore Newton now
and say I'm going to drive the equation
of motion by another way and it's an
energy technique and that as well let's
talk about the total energy of the
system it's going to be the sum of a
kinetic energy and a potential energy
okay and I'm and we'll find that even
with l'orange is a problem with forces
on systems that are what we call non
conservative things that either take
energy out of or put energy into the
system the dashpot does that dash pot
generates heat and takes energy out of
the system so I'm going to have to
ignore it for the moment so the sum of
the kinetic and the potential energies
in this problem is 1/2 K x squared for
the potential of the spring plus 1/2 M X
dot squared for the kinetic energy of
the mass and minus mg X for the
potential energy that is due to the
object moving in the gravitational field
all right and that's the total energy of
the system now and I have my problem
I've allowed no forces there's no
excitation on here this is just free
vibration only so we're talking about
make initial displacement and it
vibrates if there's no damping what can
you say about the total energy of the
system
date again I heard it over there's got
to be constant right all right well so
must this must be constant therefore the
time derivative of my system
it better be zero the energy is constant
tickets times rivets got to be zero
apply that the right hand side of this I
get K X X dot plus M X dot X double dot
minus mg X dot equals zero and I now
cancel out the common X dot terms go
away and I'm left with
and I've essentially solved for the
equation of motion of the system without
ever looking at conservation of momentum
Newton's laws only by energy
considerations okay
so that's a very simple example that you
can use energy to derive equations of
motions but you can't happen you have to
go back and fix it to account for the
loss term the damping term and that you
still have to consider it as a force
we'll find out even was the garage you
have to go back and consider the work
done by external forces okay so this
you've just kind of seen the whole
course we describe the motion we've
applied newton's laws the physics to the
direct method to derive the equations of
motion we have gone to an energy method
and have derived the equations of motion
that way and that's basically what
you're going to do in the course but now
we're now you're going to do it with
much more sophisticated tools you'll
have multiple degree of freedom systems
the description describing the motion is
maybe going to be for some of you the
most challenging part of the course and
this is a topic we call kinematics and
that's what we'll turn to next
reference frames and vectors that's the
topic this is now that we're talking
about kinematics and this is all about
describing the motion so descartes gave
us the Cartesian coordinate system and
we'll start there so imagine this is a
fixed frame we'll talk about what makes
an inertial frame then next lecture but
here we have an inertial frame and it's
the frame we'll call o XY o XY 0 for
short and in this frame maybe this is me
and up here is a dog and I'm going to
call this point a and this point B now
I'm going to describe the positions of
these two points by vectors this one
will be R and the notation that I'm
going to use is the point and it's
measurement with respect to something
well it's with respect to this point o
in this inertial frame so this is a with
respect to O is the way to read this
there's another Rebecca here this is our
B with respect to a and finally our of B
with respect to O they're all vectors on
the board I'll try to remember to
underline them in the textbooks and
things they're usually vectors are noted
as with bold letters and vector the
Loused is say the following that our
the position of the dog and the
reference with respect to o is the sum
of these other two vectors are of a with
respect to o plus RB with respect to a
and mostly to do dynamics we're really
interested in things like velocities and
accelerations so to get the velocities
and accelerations we have to take a time
derivative of our Bo DT and that's going
to give us what we'll call the velocity
I'll usually write it as V and it would
be the velocity of point B with respect
to O and no surprise it'll be the
velocity of point A plus the velocity of
B with respect to a and finally if we
take two derivatives DT squared we'll
get the acceleration of B with respect
to O and that'll be the sum of a
acceleration of a with respect to O plus
the acceleration of B with respect to a
all again vectors now just to look ahead
you know this seems all really trivial
guys are going to sleep on me right if
these are rigid bodies this is a rigid
body that is moving and maybe rotating
and B is on it and a is on it and oh
isn't on it it starts getting a little
tricky and this
the derivative of a vector that's
attached to the body somehow has to
account for the fact that if I'm the
observers on the body this other points
on the body say it's I'm honest asteroid
there's none I've got a dog out there
and the dogs running away from me the
speed of the dog with respect to me I
can measure but if I'm down here looking
at it it'll look different because it's
rotating so how do you account for all
that so taking these derivatives of
vectors in moving frames is where the
the Devils in the details and that's
part of what I have to that's part of
what I'm going to be teaching you okay
I'm still learning how to how to
maximize you know optimize my board you
haven't got it perfect yet because I'm
having to move around a lot here and
improvise but we'll persevere you need
to know a couple things about vectors
how to add them dot products if you've
had forgotten these things you need to
go back and review them really quickly
there's usually a little review section
in the books you need to practice that
sort of thing a couple other little
facts you need to remember so the
derivative of the sum of two vectors is
just the sum of the derivatives
and quite importantly we're going to
mute use of this one a lot is the
derivative of a product of two things
one of them being a vector sum function
maybe of time and a here is derivative
of F with respect to T times a plus the
derivative of a with respect to T times
F that will make a lot of use of so just
your basic calculus so now I want to
take up let's talk about the simplest
form of being able to do these
derivatives and calculate these
velocities when everything is described
in terms of Cartesian coordinates now
I'm going to give you a little look
ahead that I don't want to kind of try
to avoid confusion as much as we might
as much as possible here the hardest
problem is when you're you have a rigid
body you got the dog on it you got the
observer on it it's rotating and
translating and to take this derivative
you end up with a number of terms the
simplest problem is just something in a
fixed Cartesian coordinate system so
we're going to start with a simple one
and build our way up to the complicated
one okay but let's now we're going to do
they're really the the simplest one
we're going to do velocity and
acceleration in Cartesian coordinates
and basically I should say fixed
Cartesian coordinates not moving all
right so now let's consider my the dog
out here in his position in the
Cartesian coordinate system and I could
write that and that you'll without any
loss of generality here you'll know what
I mean if I say R be X component and I'm
going to stop writing the slash O's
because this is now all in this fixed
reference frame and it's in the I hat
direction and I've got another component
R be Y in the J hat and an RB z in the K
and I want to take the time derivative
I'm looking for the velocity I want to
calculate the velocity so the velocity
here of be in oh just D by DT of our vo
and now this is now the product of two
things so I got to use that formula over
here product one term times the other
and so forth so I go to these and I say
okay so this is r dot b x times i plus r
dot B Y times J plus r dot B Z times K
and then the other the flip side of that
is I have to take the derivatives of the
AI times RB X the derivative J and so
forth but what's the derivative of let's
say I I is the capital I is my unit
vector in the fixed reference frame my o
XY Z frame so it's a constant is unit
length and it points in a direction that
is fixed so what's its derivative okay
it's going to have a zero derivative so
the second part of this second bits of
that is zero and that's so that's the
velocity in Cartesian coordinates of
my dog out there on running around okay
and the acceleration in a similar way
you get now to get the acceleration you
take another derivative of this and
again you'll have to dig derivatives of
I J and K and again they're going to be
zero so you will find that the
acceleration then is just our double dot
X term in the I plus R double dot b y in
the j plus r double dot b z in the k
will be our acceleration term and it's
easy now imagine that we are doing this
in polar coordinates unit vectors in
polar coordinates you actually let me
check last year the students told me
that min in your physics courses you use
unit vectors R hat theta hat and K that
right so I'll use those unit vectors so
they look familiar because polar
coordinates people use lots of different
things but think about it in polar
coordinates theta you know it's a fix
maybe coordinate system but now your
theater goes like this and R moves with
theta right so the unit vector is
pointing here but over time it might
move down to here and unit vector has
changed direction and it's derivative
and time is no longer 0 so it starts
getting messy as soon as the unit
vectors change in time and so that's
when our objectives here is to get to
that point and describe how you handle
those cases
okay
so quick point about velocity you really
understand what we mean by velocity so
here's our Cartesian system here's this
point out here B now this is the dog
running around and the path of the dog
you know might have been you know like
this and right in here he's going this
direction and in a little time and delta
T he moves by an amount Delta R B with
respect to O and that's what this is
he's moved this little bit in time delta
T it happens to be going off in that
direction so this then is our prime I'll
call it of B with respect to O and this
is our original our B with respect to O
so we can say that is new position now
our B with respect to O prime is our Bo
plus Delta R these are you know all
vectors and the velocity
of B with respect to O is just equal to
this limit of Delta R Bo over delta T as
T goes to 0 so what direction is the
velocity the velocities in the direction
of the change not the original vector
but it's in the direction of the change
and in fact of the path of the dog is
like this at the point at the instant
you compute the velocity you're
computing the tangent to the path of the
dog so that's what velocity is at any
instant time is a tangent to the path
and that's a good concept to remember
you
so we're still in this fixed Cartesian
space and I have a couple of points I
make it really trivial here here's B and
here's a and the velocity of B where's
my number we'll make this 10 feet per
second and it's in the J at direction
and a lot this is the velocity of B in O
the velocity of a and O we'll say is 4
feet per second also in the J direction
and I want to know what's the velocity
of B with respect to a so now I'm
chasing the dog he's running at 10 I'm
running it at 4 and I what's my how do I
perceive the speed of the dog well to do
this in vectors which is the point of
the exercise here is we have the
expressions we started with over there
and we're going to use these a lot in
the course of the velocity of B with
respect to O is the velocity of a with
respect to O plus the velocity of B with
respect to a and you can just if I want
to know velocity with respect to a had
just all this so velocity of B with
respect to O - velocity of a with
respect to O and in this case that's 10
minus 4 is 6 in the J point of the
exercise is to manipulate the vector
expressions like this so take whatever
known quantities you have and solve for
the unknown one in this case I want to
know the relative velocity between the
two and it's this now if I that's if I'm
here and I'm watching the dog that's how
I perceive the speed of the dog relative
to me right 6 feet per second - J
direction what's the speed at the dog
from the point of view of over here the
speed of the dog relative to me so it's
again the velocity of B with respect to
a but from a different position in this
fixed reference frame
really important point actually this is
a really important conceptual point I'm
going to be bold
what sorts of speed with respect to oh
the velocity of the B with respect to a
as seen from oh it's computed from o
measured from o got radar down there and
you track it in what direction
yeah it's the same the point is it's the
same if you're in a fixed reference
frame velocity of some vector of
velocity is the same as seen from any
diff any point in the frame any fixed
point different velocity is always the
same
and in fact in this case the velocity
this is a moving point and the velocity
of him with respect to me is is a
different six feet per second and I from
here say the velocity of that guy with
respect to this guy is still six feet
per second anyplace in the fit in that
frame or even any any point moving at
constant velocity you're going to see
the same answer okay it doesn't matter
where you are to compute the velocity of
B with respect to a that's the that's
the important point okay
oK we've got to pick up with and I may
not quite finish but I am going to
introduce the next complexity okay
so the what we just what we just arrived
on a minute ago is that the velocity is
seen from O is the same as the velocity
is seen from a and a is me and I'm
moving I'm chasing the dog so I'm a
moving reference frame which what's
called a translating reference frame so
now we're going to step to take the next
step we had a fixed reference frame
before purely and now I want to talk
about having the idea concept of having
a moving reference frame within a fixed
one so this is the reference frame o
capital X Y Z and this little reference
frame now is attached to me and it's a
and I call it X prime y prime so just so
you can going to be hard to tell my this
X from this X if I don't do something
like a primer so that this is the
concept of a translating coordinate
system attached to a body like a rigid
body for example we can do lots of rigid
body dynamics here and within this
coordinate system I can compute the
velocity of B with respect to a and I'll
get exactly the same answer I get that
six feet per second in the J direction
so it's as if so this concept of being
able to have a reference frame attached
to a body and translating with it you
can measure things within it get the
answer and then convert that answer to
here if you're using you know different
coordinate you know one that meant you
could use polar coordinates here and
rectangular here but they still can be
related to one another we'll do problems
like that
okay so now I what I'm what I'm doing is
I told you like in the readings the
endgame is to be able to talk about
translating and rotating bodies and do
dynamics in three dimensions with
translating and rotating objects and
we're going to get there
somewhat step by step but I want to show
it but I want you to understand the end
games you know where we're going and you
need to have a couple of concepts in
mind so so the first concept is that
this is a rigid body now and you can
describe the rigid the motion of rigid
bodies by the summation the combination
of a translation and a rotation and of
the rigid body if you can describe this
translation and you can describe its
rotation you have the complete motion so
yeah I understand what do we mean by
what's it really the definition of
translation so translation so I've got
this call on a merry-go-round well we'll
use it we'll use in a merry-go-round an
example in a minute and you're observers
in a fixed inertial frame up above this
merry-go-round looking down on it okay
but so you can see it I got to do I got
to turn it on its side so here's my
AmeriCorp on and if it's not rotating
but let's say it's on a sitting on a
train a flatbed and moving along it's
translating and when you say a body
translates any two points on the body
move in parallel paths so two points my
thumb and my finger if I'm just going
along with this those two paths are
traveling parallel to one another
if the body does you know I got Y
pointing up the body does this
is it rotating or translating are any
two points on it moving in parallel PES
right okay so this is called when you
come when it goes through curve things
it's called curvilinear translation but
it's still just translation okay
so I'll stop and hold steady the train
stopped and the thing let it rotate so
that's pure rotation and the thing to
remember about pure rotation is that
anywhere on the body rotates at the same
rate this is going around once a second
the rotation rate is one rotation per
second 360 degrees two pi radians per
second is its rotation rate every point
on the body experiences the same
rotation rate that's a really important
one to remember
now this times if I'm holding still
merrygoround is going round around it
has a fixed axis of rotation right but
do rotating bodies have to have fixed
axes of rotation so if
I throw that up in the air there's not
hanging on to it it's got a gravity
acting on it it's rotating what's it
rotate about center of mass okay is the
center of mass moving ah so this is
clearly this is an example of rotation
plus translation it rotates about an
axis but the axis can move that's
another important concept that we we
have to allow in order to be able to do
these problems but this is now general
motion it's a combination of translation
and rotation and you figure out each of
those two pieces then we can described a
complete motion of the system all right
the where we'll pick up next time is
then doing that and this is and it would
help actually you go read that reading
especially up to chapter 16 we have to
get into being taken derivatives of
vectors which are rotating and come up
with a general formula that allows us to
do velocities and accelerations under
those conditions see you on Tuesday next